[Music]
guns guns guns guns all right uh guns
are a large part of our lives we have a
giant wall save each other all the time
we should I get new gun fights every
morning just to exercise yeah but we've
done so many videos with guns at this
point that we realized we need to do
something new for this and that means
not use plastic guns but use real cool
guns and that means it says it's real
cool gun Chinese real gun guns that are
also cool yes so basically we started by
going to our our usual shop evike and
more you're like alright let's get all
our guns and we looked at all our guns
were like right every characters get up
their own unique cool gun he's gonna
have a g36 he's gonna have a sniper
riffle
she's gonna have a mp7 and we pieced it
all out just originally going all right
we gotta have these guns match their
class but the second stage was the cool
stage because then we had to match those
fake guns to the real ones so all the
guns finally got here we loaded them
into a big old cargo van ship them
across the country as you can see
there's a couple we have in here roughly
maybe 40 replica weapons here each one
is different which is the coolest part
yeah we're going to be mashing them off
the plane
civilian is a place in New York that
rents out guns for movie shoots
I guess anything else that needs mention
guns that shoot blanks
yeah so what pretty much everything yeah
basically what these guys do with their
guns is they take the real gun and they
basically install a barrel that is
effectively blocked preventing most of
the gas and particles from going out the
other end of the barrel and then with
that they give you a special type of
ammunition that doesn't have a bullet in
it
it's basically an entire casing with a
crimped end so that way when it explodes
and fires inside the gun no actual like
debris goes down the barrel it's all
just a gunpowder explosion and with that
little gas block in the other end of the
barrel does is it makes it so that the
gun can actually continue cycling and
firing because without that block the
gas would just shoot out the other end
and there won't be enough recoil on
force to cycle the next round yes it's
really cool super sweet
defecating alright here we go
waiting for it to settle a little bit
low but is not so in battlefield all
these classes have all these different
guns so you have your support class with
big LMGs give your soul class with
normal assault rifles your engineer
typically runs with a smaller such as a
submachine gun and then you have your
recon with some sort of long-range DMR
or sniper rifle so one of the most fun
parts of the shoot though was just
simply picking out all the cool guns
that each character got to use because
we have all these characters and they
all get to have their own cool unique
guns so we try to have as little
repetition as possible and you get the
real thing - which is great the person
we have doing that was a guy named
Sparky yeah yeah great name though he'll
those real name's Matt but if ever the
first thing that said he comes in he's
like hi I'm Matt Mike I'm Matt he's like
you can also call me Sparky I'm like we
learned home Sparky after those guns
start shooting yes and he has his bus
old school bus painted green with a Mad
Max girl in the front called the Daddy
Warbucks yeah he goes to wasteland
weekend which is the Burning Man for Mad
Max enthusiasts and inside are all they
like the locked containers but that
would hold all the guns so he had his
mobile army that he would drive to set
and he was the man charge he would give
each actor their weapon and when you do
so he'd have it open he'd show them the
empty magazine he'd loaded for them pull
the trigger to prove that I was empty
and then give them the cold weapon he'd
also be the one responsible for loading
the weapons and giving him hot weapons
ever going to shoot yeah so since
ammunition blank-firing weapons don't
shoot bullets but are still dangerous in
their own way so he was really on top of
making sure there was a good safety at a
kid on set making sure that everyone
knew how their weapons functioned and
when he wasn't doing that you usually be
off to the side of the camera with
multiple belts of ammunition just draped
over his shoulder and a huge pouch just
full of like full magazines so it's
really cool when I heard little factoids
that he told me on set is we had so we
had a couple different m249 s or
basically solves our allergies and for a
civilian to own one of these with all
the tax stamps and regulations and
permits that you'd have to pay for each
gun effectively costs
$200,000 yeah it's pretty bizarre
because the thing is is the actual
equipment itself but a big machine gun
is about 10,000 bucks to get it's
expensive but not when you include the
fact that it's an automatic weapon it's
a military like weapon you're also then
modifying it so it doesn't actually
shoots so the the process to even get it
there on set it's just very expensive
months of paperwork and lots of permits
and regulations and hoops he has to jump
through so it's very funny you know
seeing him arrive on set just a giant
machine guns like ready to blast up and
knowing he's actually done a lot of
studying he's got lots of licenses he's
got lots of permits and paperwork
underneath his spell and he's actually a
very safe and responsible guy despite
his nature of worrying Chinese bikes and
holding machine guns yes so our core
group of Marines you have Miller the
assault class of the group with this g36
this trusty m4 you have McNulty
designated marksman / recon with his
sr-25 you have Ont eventually a scar you
have Haas the pilot who's the engineer
the group it gets an mp7 suite and then
you wrap it all up with ch in the
support class carrying around good
old-fashioned m249 exactly a lot of guns
and also you see CMC's are also another
cool group because we're looking at
these characters who are overseas in in
another country and so they're they're
kind of not using the most high-tech of
weapons they're using more trusty ones
so with Braddock's character carrying
around a really tactical ak-47 cos
that's probably the type of ammunition
the country uses we have a breeze
character
carrying around this really cool Sako
TRG or something it doesn't lob why no
no that's the name of the bullet she has
a sick-ass sniper rifle mm naturally and
it was really sweet fully auto good luck
yeah that's super cool and then we have
our sturgis a character with a vest
errors we have ster just carrying around
a vector naturally who's our engineer
yeah come on
it's an engineer thing and then you have
our Marsden on support for the PMC's
using a m4 with a giant freaking drum
mag on there so I think that's a good
blend of you know support class
you know practicality see everything's
blended you know it's like you want some
things to be realistic and then you want
just things to get a little goofy and
just use the cool guns from the game so
it's kind of a nice little mix
[Music]
[Music]